in the right space you've got a hotel
right and they want to employ a decision
support system okay that's kind of the
usually start thinking DSS when you see
something like sales analysis analysis
as the key processor with you so what
they want to do is have a DSS that has
all of this local data within it ok so
that would be like the knowledge base
right and then can use all of that data
and historical patterns from the past to
try to predict okay is there likely to
be a lot of guests on a certain date or
not many guests on a certain day okay
and there are two go to people who are
going to use this data but I'm already
getting ahead of myself let's look at
the first question identify participant
in this decision support system and for
each provide the example of where a bit
provide example a decision where the
system will be able to assist okay so
super super easy I everything is
actually back in this paragraph okay so
let's read again the package is to be
used by the management of the hotel to
allow them to better predict the number
of guests likely to use the hotel on a
week-to-week basis okay so just right
there there's the overarching purpose on
the system but what specific ways will
be used okay next centers management can
then adjust staffing level more
efficiently BAM answer number one okay
so I'm gonna hit okay and where we're
trying to work out through the
participants now remember what
distinguishes a participant from an end
user is what distinguishes a
participatory loser
directly involved yeah that's that's a
good way to put it in fact you might
remember from the prelim course that
participant another name for participant
is direct use up 40 and another name for
end users in directories up okay so add
users they benefit from the system but
they're not making any of the processes
happened okay if you name your seven
information processors collecting
organizing analyzing story TV and so on
right the end you aren't actually making
it even happen they were benefit from
those processes but they're not making
them they don't initiating than the way
participant up okay so coming back we
identified the first group okay so we
could call them hotel management I guess
okay now what was the specific decision
that they were going to be looking at it
was about gauging staffing levels right
so making a decision about how many
people they should employ on a given day
okay you know we're going to peak
periods we need lots of stuff on those
days I mean you're not too bellboys to
take luggage two rooms really lots of
cleaners to make sure all the rooms are
tidy of ready for new guests and so on
okay so there's our first group of
participants what process are they going
to be initiating do you think what would
you guess you get the seven processes
now if they're trying to make a decision
about staffing levels right there try to
take some trends and so future data
right and they try to get some something
meaningful out of it in terms of what
should I do with the future okay so if
they try to get something meaningful out
there taking data until you to
information this is going to be analysis
now you didn't have to say it's
analyzing right but it's just for you to
identify your head okay have I got have
I got participants or I really think you
have a net user okay curl be back to the
question next sentence the sales team
will use the product to predict x fo
occupancy services okay so another group
now again
they're doing analyzing okay and they're
analyzing the same kind of data but this
is important it's a different kind of
decisions right the sales team has
nothing to do with how many people they
employ what does the sales do you have
to do like what kind of decisions are
they going to make if you're the sales
team of a hotel what do you think your
responsibilities are what do you what
are you in charge of sales to our eyes
perfect okay so if I want to think about
you know that where I advertise and when
I advertise right advertising is really
expensive okay so it's not in your
interest to advertise all the time if
some periods you're going to get lots of
people anyway like a Christmas you don't
necessarily need to advertise because
lots of people are on holidays so
they're going to come to your hotel
anyway right whereas have you noticed
you doing stuff like a who's doing a
hungry jack they're doing Tuesday's
Tuesday's right and I think Domino's
they do they do a cheaper Tuesday
cheaper Monday thing as well okay why
are they doing that the sales team in a
very similar way to this kind of
decision support system they've looked
at their weekly trends okay Wendy thinks
the most popular time for hungry jacks
or pizza I think windsor miss popular
would you guess we can't write Friday
Saturday Sunday because that's what
people party and they have like you know
gatherings of people where they don't
have to cook all the food right my dad
shoes there was a Thursday those are
weeknights their school nights we don't
have birthday parties or grand finals or
you know those kinds of things on week
notes cuz you got to get up and go to
work the next day or school the next day
or whatever okay so advertising is going
to be targeted according to these less
busy periods
okay so can you see it's the same kind
of process underneath both right but
these are two completely different
decisions right so two groups of
participants to decisions that was part
that's all is the puppy is this hotel
decision support system best describes
work in structured semi-structured or
unstructured situation justify your
response okay so here's a clue for here
okay I'll eat it at least at a nature
cesium your answer for this question on
any situation is almost always going to
be semi structured okay here's why if it
was structured right it might be it
might appear in an example it's not very
interesting okay there aren't many
variables you can't really ask a
question like Part C it's not that
interesting when it's just a look it's
straightforward inputs and
straightforward outputs okay it's not as
challenging a scenario in the same way
an unstructured situation like questions
like what's your favorite band what's
the best music you know those kinds of
things what's the best picture again you
can't ask very many beautiful questions
about them right so it's semi structured
the question is why semi-structured one
of them what are the kinds of factors
that affect where something is on the
structure continuum all kinds of factors
do we think about
variables good now what you say
variables what do you mean because i'll
i can think of a couple of different
meanings of variables in this scenario
both would be valid i just want to do
what y'all think you okay alright so
you're you're thinking of now you've
just said two different things you said
variables and that you set outcomes or
decisions or recommendations ok let's go
variables first I might suggest the
variables are things like say whether
we're there is notoriously difficult to
predict for Eddie you know like the time
I've generally more than three days is
very very unpredictable ok so you've got
some unpredictable things here in your
situation if I there was good weather or
bad weather how would that have an
impact on this particular system what
good weather bad weather what do you
think bad weather might lead to bad
weather what issues by that cause for
things like this
thank you let's get us through this
step-by-step let's just think of a
scenario that's a major sporting
attitude events okay so you're the hotel
manager right and your hotel is right
next to like some big stadium okay and
the grand finals coming up so what are
you going to predict is going to happen
around you do before during and after
the days of the grand final as a hotel
what are you gonna predict more people
simple prediction right so you've got
this date your mind you say okay that
time can be tons of extra stuff right
and then you get really it just it rains
and thunders off it's on fire or
something like that okay you're getting
covered whether for whatever reason
what's going to happen to your
prediction it's going to be invalid
right because maybe this event either it
gets cancelled or it goes ahead but less
people want to go because the weather is
lousy right so you've got unpredictable
elements in here right but at the same
time you know the inputs and the
outcomes that are going into this and
relating to each other they're actually
quite want to find right these these are
well defined the data that you've got
stuff like historical patterns right oh
not just you start with weather
forecasts but how do people have we had
every day of the year for the last 10
years okay that's very very well defined
data it's it's measurable its
quantitative okay so it's easy to put
into a system right so that's why you've
got these two elements that's what the
justify your response is going to be
looking for okay you identify
semi-structured and then you say why
because it has these elements of an
unstructured problem and it has these
elements of a structured problem okay
all right we're on to the last question
here we go the results at a for this
system student theory improve the
profitability of hotels however as
possible the results could be a radius
radius just means role like era era
discuss the effects of negative results
and who would be responsible for these
negative results okay now don't get you
through it off I know is discussed was
just two mugs okay so you didn't have to
have a super lengthy response when it
says discuss the effects of the negative
results what I think of is I go back to
my my answers to partay okay because
there are two different decision to you
and therefore if the results are wrong
they'll affect these two decisions
differently okay so let's suppose
management makes a poor decision okay
because the results are erroneous what
are the negative results going to be for
these guys I can think of two
possibilities yeah right so let's think
of that a scenario we said with a
sporting event right and it gets rained
out okay so be seen that's funny about
coming on that day we would have
adjusted staffing level to say let's
double the number of cleaners bellboys
other concierges and all those kinds of
people who are going to hire okay but
then when the day comes because it gets
rained out all these people just sit
around doing nothing but you still gotta
pay him right so you're over staffed
naturally the opposite could also happen
it you'd be understaffed that you've got
all these people who require your
service right okay what about the sales
team what might happen if they make the
wrong decision okay probably not as big
an impact as the other guys but if
they're advertising is tired at adapt
you which is popular anyway right there
just wasting advertising dollars yeah if
on the other hand right they miss a
period which is very very unpopular and
they don't advertise right you'll have
very consistently low occupancy rate so
as a hotel you just get a lot back money
okay who's going to be responsible
really quickly
these guys the system now this property
is important it's my last point okay the
system isn't making a statement of fact
okay it's just making a prediction right
so it's a future looking DSS okay and
most of them are right there for but
this has hands these guys a prediction
it says I can't make a decision okay
it's very different from saying right
now right if you had a decision support
system and its job was to assess a
current situation and make a statement
about okay how many fires are going on
right now one of their severity okay now
if that system was flawed and made a
wrong assessment of where the worst
fires were there probably the designers
of the system would be a fault they're
okay but he is just the prediction
everyone knows that our predictions can
be wrong and so it's kind of like well
the humans involved have to make a
decision based on the prediction and if
it's accurate or inaccurate based on
unpredictable elements that's not the
system's fault it's just a pretty cute
okay so ultimately responsibility lies
with the decision makers okay